or est grosse annonce aujourd'hui guez
premièrement si vous avez cliqué sur le
podcast vous savez maintenant qu'on ne
refait notre branding mais c'est pas la
seule chose qu'on vous annonce
aujourd'hui d'hommes qu'est-ce qu'on a
annoncé mais le plaisir de vous annoncer
qu'on passe à deux pas de casse par
semaine
oh my god cas ce mardi comme d'habitude
ça change et doivent voter rendez vous
de mardi
ça va rester l'autre jour mon podcast
les mardis mais en plus ce vendredi boom
un deuxième pack lens met en mode le
productivité faut dire folle sommes
qu'au fait que mettait vendredi à votre
agenda par ci un nouveau podcast qui va
sortir vos sans filtre à toutes les
semaines
puis on va voir si vous aimez ce fait
que mr cela guen houllier production du
f mais à nous sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter dati
site super canton avec moi dôme plantes
cette semaine mais vous l'avez déjà
entendu une autre grosse annonce c'est
qu'on passe à deux podcasts par semaine
fait que vendredi
cochet seul dans votre calendrier on est
encore là sinon c'est cette semaine en
fait aujourd'hui parce que le cette
semaine et deux personnes mais
aujourd'hui nous aujourd'hui on a réussi
on s'entretient avec nahd et que vous
avez sans doute connu à occupation
double od chez nous elle s'est vraiment
démarqué dans ses missions le comme
quelqu'un de super mature ce parcours 10
par intelligent avec un regard vraiment
clair seules situations un super plaisir
s'entretenir avec elle on a parlé de
prince show de son parcours de son
expérience bien sûr occupation double
mais aussi des expériences de vie
parfois plus difficile de raconter une
des relations câlinant sa vie qui était
vraiment vraiment difficile ça nous
aurons un petit peu
ce double à mener sur le chemin de la
philosophie de la réflexion sur le
couple sur les relations sur qu'est-ce
que l'amour ce qu'est ce qu'un amour
saint leu soit la conversation comme on
aime à voir ces jours ci c'est des
questions qu'on se pose qui nous qui
nous tracasse mon âme sans discuter de
différentes personnes alors vraiment pas
grand prix je pense qu'on n'est pas les
seuls à se poser ces questions là c'est
toute une génération complète fait que
avant d'écouter le podcast on va aller
remercier nos sponsors
oui on est très heureux d'annoncer
officiellement fait notre nouveau
partenariat avec auch lag est une micro
brasserie et distilleries québécoise
avec qui on a déjà collaboré dans le
passé mais qu'il advienne le fournisseur
officiel de breuvages alcoolisés du
studio et servent donc ça veut dire que
n'importe qui qui loue le studio peut se
servir dans notre mini frigo qui est au
coin là et déguster les produits
hochelaga aller chercher les produits
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment beau c'est
une petite équipe au québec qui
travaillent de façon soudé avec des
ingrédients majoritairement québécois
appelé lance avec les texans vient des
nouveaux produits d'un petit goûter
parlant de tuer j'ai essayé les sens ce
qu'on appelle ça c'est une eau
pétillante alcoolisées donc c'est super
légers c'est vraiment ça a un petit goût
sucré mais pas trop
c'est carrément de l'eau pétillante on
sera même pas vraiment compte que c'est
alcoolisées même donc pour cet été sur
le bord des piscines sur la plage sur le
bord de l'eau ou soleil pour rester
hydraté vous restez quelque chose de
léger et de frais les selles dures c'est
vraiment quelque chose moi je viens
justement de me prendre un petit centre
goya c'était délicieux
ils sont le citron ici on en manque je
recommande fortement
il ya ainsi d'autres des récits manière
de la 2d pineau j'aime les pays avec le
jeu vous aimez doublement ce on est
aussi la bière parmi grenade touche de
fruits et plein d'autres sauveteurs beau
produit chez roche la pièce avec merci
beaucoup pour la longue collaboration et
qui sont maintenant que faisait
fournisseur officiel du studio et s'est
fait que baba le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté encore une fois pas
refléter un pic flec-pm pixlr réseau
social pour encourager le commerce local
comment ça fonctionne en fait s'est créé
un compte sur full ip fixe le tu peux
commencer à partager des coups de coeur
la cour mettons un petit café projet
chez ou qui fait de l'art dans ton là
t'es tu prends une photo de dire que
tout le monde qui te suit peut découvrir
ce commerce la inversement tu peux tu
abonnés à des gens que je connais et
découvrir leurs coups de coeur de
commerces locaux et en partageant des
coutures et en s'abonnant à ceux des
autres tu accumules des flips sociale
une cure une scic rupture comme tôt que
réussit à ckoi défi social fait passer
les points si la monnaie d'échangé
flamand sur les techniques vous
accumulez car vous possédez des ddd des
photos de vos commerces préférez vous
accumulez ces points là et après sont
les échanges quand toutes sortes de
cadeaux de bonus de des gratuités
d'offres exclusives jeu par le fon trop
nouveau partenariat avec lesquels fait
pipi qui est fait à faire c'est bixi
c'est comme une auto essais et va donc
toutes des choses qui servent à se
déplacer donc si vous arrive ça vous
arrive des fois de vous déplacer comme
la plupart des as du mans ça peut être
super
ce par la fnac les avis aux petits
points et vous prenez votre ever votre
bic si votre communauto ça peut vous
coûter presque rien évidemment avec ces
points là on a un code promo csf le
calme ça vous donne 10000 points 10 mai
le flip sociale d'un coup et les offres
exclusives commence à 15000 donc cette
presque rendu à avoir des petits bonus
ps merci pépé cuillère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier c'est parti n'a de merci 7,9 sur
embarquée dans la discussion qu'on
compte qu'on avait avant dans le fond je
savais pas que j'avais faite au doux nom
je pense que je pense qu'on est quand
même on a un profil quand même assez
semblable de gens qui sont allés au bout
des pieds qui en avait aucune crise dit
qu'ils savaient pas quoi le tue oui je
sais pas quoi stats s'attendaient
maintenant qu'ils ont pas envie de dire
tous même temps
mais pas parce que c'était négatif quoi
que ce soit mais juste parce que tu
chantes j'ai fait le topping tft cool
mais je sais pas pour toi mais je pense
à me vraiment protégés de pour savoir
que c'était dans quoi je m'embarquais
puis je pense que j'avais des attentes
qui étaient comme à 0 ouais je fais
comme peut être discuté ouais je suis
pas bien tu dis que jamais écouté c'est
vrai c'est tellement est omniprésent
s'étoffe à éviter gel c'est pour ça
rentre dans l'est je parle souvent de ce
concept lf j'aimerais ça qu'on espère
comme victimes de nos algorithmes on est
en vie dans un bus ou un thé où on est
confronté pas magistrat d'aisé pignon
est similaire au nôtre orienté avec des
gens qui ont un peu les mêmes des clean
up qui consomment les mêmes choses que
nous y fait que je pense que c'est une
réalité dans un certain sir camp nou par
un coup l'émission quand nos amis
coutume si on a vraiment l'impression
qui systématiquement à chaque fois que
je fais comme une entrevue ans que je
m'entretiens avec quelqu'un on ne
désespère jamais coûté au dipj comme un
gros genre non mais dis moi mes parents
écoutent post
il ya des amis qui lui coûte mais c'est
bien mais attention pas vocale mais
c'est fou ce que ce que tu décris là que
mes tantes et dont on ne peut on est
dans même génération puis témoigne pas
même si je voulais ne pas l'écouter je
me ferais garrocher d'en face des
informations par rapport à od anyways ne
serait ce que par du monde que je suis
ami aux seconds a effectivement touché
même dame et on imagine je te connais
pas beaucoup même très très peu mais de
ce que j'ai écouté de toit puis regardez
de toit depuis qu'on sait que tu veux
venir sur le podcast
j'ai le feeling qu'on a des opinions
mais ton politique assez semblable des
idées sur la société un peu de gauche à
ses semblables
puis malgré ce on est quand même dans
deux bulles du citoyen puisse assez
débile dans le fond le temps d'imaginer
que même dans une espèce de même la même
génération dans le même courant d'idées
il ya quand même des bulles fait que ça
en dit long sur comment il ya des bulles
énorme si tu sais si tu sors de sa voix
dans des générations différentes dans
des idées politiques différentes dans
les choses comme ça c'est utile
défensivement et oui définitivement
je pense que c'est de le et que vient
cette difficulté à se comprendre dans
une rentrée dans les enfers trou
diplomate un métier dans une même dans
une même société
il ya des courants dits qui se
croiseront jamais risqué tu veux juste
évolué en parallèle comme ceux
exactement parce que tu es un gars comme
toi une fille comme moi puis c'est
pourtant je dois je le regarde on tourne
de l'air de on pourrait en temps sans
doute mais probablement que sans cette
émission laisse un peu de casse
on se serait jamais croisés c'est une
des affaires qu'on voulait faire avec
lui avec le podcast à dire 2
démocratiser la conversation de ces la
discussion fait que recevoir des gens
avec qui on pourrait pas s'asseoir
normalement par les 1h30 2h puis juste
ses shoots de shit avec quelqu'un qu'on
rencontre pop et au final c'est
exactement ce qui se passe
des fois les idées fausses idylle qui
évoluent en parallèle finissent par se
croiser cas qu il une idée d'un bord ou
de l'autre qui fait tellement de bruit
qui a réussi à aller chercher jusqu'à
l'autre bord le team étant je pense à
l'exemple du béton de d'arnaud soli le
type ces vidéos humoristiques et skip a
redit des conspirationnistes henry
mathon d'habitude fsi vidéo le monde qui
suit long et qui connaissent regarde ce
qu'on prenne du mot comprennent le dégré
trouve ça drôle tout mais là ces vidéos
lot tellement fait de chemins totalement
marché qui sert à l'inversé l'autre
s'est rendu jusqu'au monde qui part
redit qui normalement sont politiquement
stable le christ avait posté une drogue
avait posté kyste et golos avait passé
six ans rennes rire 2 août en rien de
sérieux ou le supplée ça crée une espèce
de clash plus celle que le monde aussi
genre ça fait ça c'est le pire du mardi
4 euros tandis que jamais qui c'est qui
tellement éloigné de ce que tu conçois
de la réalité qui est papote imaginer
que c'est vrai tout cela complète folie
mais choqué ce superbe exemple qui donne
parce que moi mettons à new delhi ça
fait trois semaines que chez ceux qui a
way dit et puis on s'est écrit vraiment
brièvement sur instagram pis la seule
raison pour laquelle je tombe sur têt le
mot ce dont tu parle d'aucune dans leur
tâche dans le décor qui parle et moi je
l' ai découvert parce que et italie sur
un podcast dernier bon ami lingot qu'est
j'aime vraiment beaucoup
jeff la jespo ya ce week end en double
l'omnium du peuple ouais exact voilà qui
est tu me dire s'engager
je suis ce qu'il fait j'aime vraiment ce
qui fait maison de travailler ensemble
dans la sphère musicale mais tonton ne
fétez on a fait des trucs en sort avec
des doubles is puis à cause de ce je
suis tombé sur ce podcast loupé c'est
comme ça que j'ai découvert arnaud soli
métier le mot je réalise que c'est une
personne que je vaux qui est un
incontournable qui lui qui le dit mais
c'est fou mais c'est fou ne peut être
pas découvert parce que comme +51 québec
c'est ce qui différencie du québec qui
commence dit des fois se croiseront
jamais à moins de un glitch dans le
système comme ceux le terrain pour nous
seuls ip un yes we can qui sait quoi toi
ton québec mettons c'est quoi le québec
auquel est exposé quelques au québec
auquel tu t'intéresses ou si c'est coton
c'est sexy et drôle à dire parce que je
suis comme un genre d'hybride un peu
bizarre au sens où et c'est moi j'ai
grandi à rouyn noranda dans un québec
asseyez normal c'est ce que je disais
tantôt parce que pour beaucoup de
personnes noires de marcoing mais
mettons-les lalonde noir l'on parle des
autres et qui m'a dicté sa change
tranquillement le mets mes piques hanche
arrivé à montréal et devient caraquet
l'année tout à fait moi mettons pour te
dire en quelle année j'ai réduit
fortement que je calcule avec mettons
amis d'aguilar en 2002
puis à ce moment là j'ai comme réalisé
qu'il y avait plein d'autres réalités
auxquelles j'avais jamais été exposée
petit je m'éloigne un peu ta question
mais ce qui était super intéressant pour
moi c'est que j'arrive en tant que des
juges je me considère pas dans une cage
y même peu à ce moment là la notion que
différentes catégories tu sais que
j'arriverai en secondaire 4 et j'ai été
élevé par une mère qui vient d'abitibi
mes cousines son étui blanc du bleu et
j'arrive ici pires que j'ai juste -
est-ce que tu t'es consciente de ta
différence en libye tune on sait ce que
l'on te l'armée d'en face ou jamais
quand même si j'en ai parlé une couple
de fois mais c'est comme un genre de j m
pascal canfin tu te rends pas compte de
ces choses loin des spots à moins que
les autres dans faster en trois actes
exact oui c'est quelque chose que j'ai
développée sans est capable de le nommer
ou 1 sans être capable de nécessairement
comprendre c'est comme si je sentais que
chez différents mais j'avais pas cette
notion le de race de couleur ou quoique
ce soit fait que tu es juste comme il ya
deux mondes qui même pour moi parce que
il muté ou qu'ils me traitent de manière
différente mais j'ai jamais comme je
n'ai jamais dit c'est à cause jamais
jamais jamais 4 chez ptc j'en ai parlé
d'un bar d'en doter dans d'autres
criques mais si c'est comme vraiment
après que j'ai réalisé riches et même
peut-être qu'ils avaient peut-être moins
de gens de races la dame à ce que peu
importe
m quand tu arrives échanges arrivée à
montréal m
eli lilly groupe si t'arrives le à
montréal tu es nouvellement promu ton
seront leurs quatre qui mange c'est la
caf le jeu peut se comprendre le concept
d'arrivée mais d'être vraiment que
l'offre dans le sas dit
élite j'aime les gens qui sont venus
quitter comme tu es bros vient manger
exorbités dont le tiche leur propre
argent parce que ça marche pas mais
c'est les blacks sont arrivés le petit
j'étais bloquée personne si c'est
l'effet haïtienne et les filles
africaines méfie même dominicaine
infectés c'est devenu ma réalité parce
qu ils se sont dit georges drouin neuf
ça s'ébruite en quittant prises pour
fournir avec elle parce que j'avais pas
cette notion de concept le dgt jusqu'en
berck et c'est là la belle c'est
l'ignorance et de la jeunesse d'accord
tout le monde est pareil le papy qui
cessa puis éventuellement ben c'est ce
qui m'a permis de connaître différents
et faire un milieu différent des
différentes strates je te dirai de
l'imec puis le ménage beaucoup plus
consciente que justement il certains
médias il ya certes un certain connus
qui se rendront jamais dans toute l'île
dans toutes les couches ou quand
évidemment pas parce que tu es venu avec
un marteau juste diego qui suivait
s'arrêter comme vraiment
on parle et on a reçu quand même
expliqué celui qui a grandi à québec le
dans le même quartier que moi en fait le
puits à une époque aussi où ces québec
et beaucoup de diversité
c'est encore beaucoup mais le plus de
jeu qui lui tenait donc inquiet vu
corneilla tv il cire connu ma première
fois noté pigeons a raconté l'histoire
de thé y'avait telle ou telle cote le
traité le trench coat danse on danse on
dans son clip qui est à ses parents
chevreuil se conclut l'ont été parce
qu'ils lui après toi est ce qui m est on
avec l'absence de deux de gens de
couleur autour de toi ce qu est ce que
naturellement tu vas chercher des
modèles dans dans la culture ou même
vous pas nécessairement un exemple
jeunes exemple un peu oui et sert à
faire parce que je prends vraiment
beaucoup et que c'est important dès
jeudi j'étais curé les autres manger
souvent le mercure point la
représentation c'est quelque chose qui
est primordial et c'est pour plusieurs
raisons mais pour moi il ya aussi un
volet qui est important c'est que dans
le fond c'est comme le droit à
l'identité d'un sens que j'ai
l'impression que à cause du nombre comme
un film de représentation des minorités
ont fini par avoir vraiment très peu de
modèles puis des fois ça peut être des
puces des fois ça peut être un peu
restreignant puis le jeu donnait
l'exemple de on va dire
fais moi en grande synthe et un gain est
acquis je m'associais beaucoup parce que
pour moi est noirci une couleur c'est
une identité mais c'est pas la totalité
des qui joue dans ce sens qu'est
j'aimerais ça qu'on arrive à un point où
est ce que maintenant ça veut dire
qu'ils émanent tu peux être dans un
groupe de death metal c'est satan pions
sans but puis ça veut pas dire que parce
que les modèles ressemblent à ceux tcc
quand un éventail plus grand de modèle b
et hip hop dgid de canal à la boîte qui
tu peux faire c'est exactement fait que
si oui j'ai eu des modèles mais en même
temps et je peux les modèles classiques
je te dirai jamais douté de ski des doc
martens la chemise de chastes et je peux
si c'est ce qui c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est moi je revendique vraiment
beaucoup parce que je trouve que c'est
une liberté qu'on a beaucoup quand on
est dans la majorité mais que dans la
minorité on a moins de modèles comme ça
c'est vrai qu'on en parle très peu de
com là précisément cet aspect là dessus
on parle de représentativité mes propres
principalement dans les médias mais
c'est aussi dans carrément tout le
toutes les sphères de la vie qui font
que que t'es pas que t'es pas se fier à
genève un style vestimentaire aussi con
parce que je n'avais jamais pensé ce que
tu viennes sur l'île de dire et moi je
me reconnais pas pantoute dans beyoncé
comme un gamin guerre comme un casse à
beckham un kaka ska comporte mais comme
si c'est mon modèle c'est parce qu'il ne
peut nier ce que nous augmentons c'est
moi le tir des styles vestimentaires des
stèles des styles de musique de vianne à
utah mac miller qui fait j'ai pop qui
faisaient de j-pop que n'importe quel
bum de métal scandinave
c'est comme tout ça et les wampas et
tant de filles robin tu peux aussi ces
fous pareils j'avais jamais j'avais
jamais réalisé sur ces ça ça ça sent
aussi des plaines manière quand tu
penses à un gars comme l onas x quand il
est sorti et il fallut en fait lui avait
avec charité et dans le country
tranquillement peuvent être sa chance on
a commencé à vraiment est placé super
bien puis éventuellement ceux qui sont
en charge des charts country ont dit
banco dépend quand j'étais chao sadoudi
peut-être la pop fait qu'ils ont ils ont
sorti des charts qui est fallut en fait
qu'est ce que son nom et il fallut qui
en bas c'est pour ça qu'il fit en fait
parce qu'il est et non chanson conduit
le sait et kiev est un virus qui les lie
chat quand j avais pas le choix parce
que à un versement dans précisément cet
exemple quand taylor swift avait gagné
un prix pour le country le monde déjà
c'est du peuple ça n'a rien à voir avec
du country ce que vous dites là puis le
stage annoncée du country au café des
rappeurs blanche diana plaint depuis
longtemps quand même le titre a dit ce
qui est des chanteurs country noir il ya
le monde
le plafond est comme plus dur à passer
une côté là et c'est pour ça que des
fois il ya des insatisfactions
je sais que c'est difficile à comprendre
dix fois et pitt et je pense que c'est
le but et peut décemment de segmenter
pudeur et youtube blanc pour le retour
du rap je ne sais pas c'est juste que ça
serait le fun que creuse de bordes et
cette fluidité le on puisse en profiter
aussi de l'autre côté si on y met un mac
miller ou un peu importe c'est dit si
tel talent pour le faire ce avec forme
le comme il faut bon ok c'est bon ça
devrait pas nécessairement avoir
d'impact la couleur qui était apprécié
ma job un mixtape conduisent ça me
tenterait qui pensent la même affaire
c'est la vidéo qu'on a regardé duguay du
droit mais d'une façon m'attraper son
nom le qui attend pour la première fois
intéressante mais je sais quoi sont
faits drama l'analyste 73 meur noire des
affaires des dégâts spock darwin mais il
y est ce que les gens aimaient les
vidéos sur youtube c'est lui qui a
atteint la touche enter sandman de
metallica pour la première fois s'est
déjà saisie et vieux le karma véhicules
pas mal il s'est amusé cosim et la fête
dans sa bulle musicale a jamais écoutés
en deux semaines quand même fou de
scénario et c'est quand même un peu sa
demande je promène mettons au québec je
promène à place laurier tu vas
l'entendent
les deux chemins se croiseront jamais ça
me rappelle un autre chose que j'ai vue
justement douter des des blacks
commentait de la musique td gros
classiques qui ont jamais entendu qu'ils
entendent justement jo rin des dalits
peine ils sont comme les vidéos du lac
chine justement de béton qui sait qu'il
est 16e succès du choc dans sa ville
gentil très près de ta pote c'est pas
que j'aime pas ce il sait pas qui ont
jamais entendu ce parce qu'ils aiment
pré post c'est juste ça jamais cru dans
leur chambre ou pareil c'est débile toit
dans le fond qu'un que parce que l'iec
j'ai écouté ton année à eau des puits
puis je trouvais que je prenais des
positions tu skies polanski est pas
quelque chose que tout le monde fait
dans vie en général dans les positions
assez clair tu étais tu étais tu avais
pas de verbaliser tes idées at on
indiqué je trouvais ça super cool mais
est ce que c'est quelque chose que tu as
commencé à fermer ton jeunes de
comprendre position sur des des idéaux
politiques ou sociaux mettons-la être
vocale par rapport à devenir un peu
active et sans guillemets pour des
causes qui est de réaliser qui était
d'aider des causes qui était un balancer
ou cdd injustices sociales font comme
son nom ou c'est juste je pense que
c'est vraiment prêter quand il décrit
mais je pense j'ai juste la tête four
qui mesure moins si je pense que c'est
même pas je me suis pas nécessairement
dit que j'allais prendre position en
onze ans et je pense que je pense ça
doit juste faire partie toi je pense que
oui mais en fait ça me rappelle le genre
d'anecdotes un peu un peu drôle je
regardais le g comme un bulletin de
garderie ok j'ai ma mère pis à dix
et que je te bats un film mais que des
fois je défends des et les autres
enfants 6 faisait comme voler leurs
jouets piquer des fois c'était comme de
deroff
oui j'étais un peu recruté pour les
jardins justice de jouer puis fait que
je pense que ça fait quand même partie
de moi depuis longtemps je suis
définitivement lamy et que les amis
peut-être un petit peu plus un peu plus
soft et pour qui et quand y avait
quelque chose qui avait porté le tlfi
appétit fine avec moi plus je débarquais
jeter comme gentiment mon amitié
en fait je me suis bien battu cluj a
perdu ce week end mais non c'est ça je
peux et j'aime vraiment peut en venir à
la violence est choqué c'est trouve que
c'est souvent une arme pourrait pourrait
quand on me fait dire à mon avis à moi
et voilà mais par contre oui je pense
que je pense que je prend peut-être plus
de temps à me forger une opinion piget
jeu valu beaucoup les faits puis je vais
faire l'avocat du diable je m'assurer
d'être vraiment solide
mais une fois que solide je vais tenir
mon bout parce que moi j'ai un moment
clé dans ma tête
ou est-ce que l'on l'écoutant ensemble
en fait c'est là où est ce que je me
rappelle j'ai fait de la crise je
m'habille et solide en tabarnak en ce
moment puis c'était en fait c'était dans
l'heure de vérité je pense puisque là il
y avait majoré cynthia qui parlait pleut
margerie a comme allah comme do l'espèce
d'affaires comme de quoi le fallait
accepter son comportement sous prétexte
que c'est un couple homosexuel qui était
pas excepté depuis leur tout c'était
juste le but a fait non toutes les repas
ton orientation sexuelle pour justifier
un comportement de marbre et puis moi je
me rappelle m'être dit crise dans ce
sujet le mois j'aurai chaillot et de
cette conversation le jeu n'aurait pas
parce que je pensais pas que toi te dis
au contraire je pense absolument cette
version-là de comme tu peux pas utiliser
je manque au lit ce que tu sois lesbien
du pot seulement une phobie ou pain où
je manquerais sur ce que tu peux pas
utiliser ça pour justifier un
comportement de merde picard était
reproché à n'importer qui aurait été la
prochaine importe qui peut importe
l'orientation sexuelle mais moi mettons
mois gérard chaillou et de ce débat là
j'aurais fait et creuse même jamais un
combat qui combat que je veux tu veux
engager parce qu'après c'est le backlash
qui peut avoir que tu risques d'avoir je
sais pas si tu en as upi mais ce moi je
trouvais ça une scène que tu décides de
poche ayo et de signer un beau lotis
alors que c'est comme ceux qui trient
sur des millions personnes qui checke ça
puisse quand même un sujet qui touchait
la barre mal même si dans l'absolu je
suis d'accord avec le point parce
qu'évidemment qui a eu de la
discrimination politiquement encore pas
très joli petit mais ça veut pas dire
que dans cette situation précise le tout
on parle celle que le titre est bien une
coupe d'autrefois comme sun en séries
puis j'imagine qu'est ce que c'est que
ce c'est quelque chose que tu fais pas
par la force dans ton quotidien
je pense que oui en fait non choquer oui
et c'est drôle parce que dans cet
exemple que tu nommes on avait et bien
maintenant que chic de fait aux 10 très
drôle mais tu le sais comment ça marche
avant ce super league et comme c'est une
longue période où tout le monde dehors
ils ont atteint 3 ans qui on avait eu
des discussions et je t'aiderai la
presse que la totalité des l'équipe à ce
moment là je pense que ses deux fils a
été ailleurs en train de gérer ou de
choses puis c'est le consensus général
était exactement celui de tout le monde
était comme elle
ça podhaler mais tout le monde le disait
le personne voulait dire quand cette
femme prend la parole mais en fait c'est
que tout le monde le dit d'avant c'était
comme auch paris peut être par exemple
et tout le monde était comme
sérieusement et on peut tout mettre dans
le même panier puis il ya des choses qui
qui qui sont juste pas de lien enfin on
monte puis si je pense à kiki par
exemple citer comme témoin sérieusement
j 1 trillion d'information aux maamar ma
possession
mais j'ai pas envie d'en parler par je
me sens trop vulnérable jeu sans trop
que mes propos pourraient sortir
peut-être d'une manière que je dis que
je contrôle pas puis après cet eagle et
10 de la production qui je veux juste
peut être peint comme le bas de gamme
lada pas si glissant en tabarnak dans
son cas il ya un conflit d'intérêts dans
son ski ça peut être avoir de la de
tulle lavage de linge sale temps ce que
toi tu n'étais pas dans situation mais
en même temps j'étais dans une position
où il était comme inside me avec des
décodeurs et fax qui auraient pu ceux
qui auraient pu être discutés comme hors
de tout doute en fait je serais ce que
je dis c'est comme mettez ça ça lui
appartient pythie me jugent les jeunes y
compris puis l'annoncé d'avant souci
était comme du mouvement mais je parie
que ce puits b c des fois ça serait
peut-être demain 6h et c'est ça le sera
parce que ses comptes avaient eu
maintenant comme comme retour de ce bain
c'est parce que moi dans ma tête à moi
prétend que c'est juste parce que
ce que j'avais marqué puis j'ai pas
écouter activement au modem et celle là
je l'écouté puis dans ma tête à moi
c'était comme une espèce de la prise de
position la plus la plus claire de
l'émission c'est de ce que j'ai moi
j'avais vu au moins fait que c'est que
c'est un moment marquant peut-être que
celle n'était pas pour tout le monde
qu'on n'entend n'a même pas entendu
parler mais dessus en retour sur ce
cette prise est possible ou est ce que
tu disais tout ce que tout ce que tout
le monde
possiblement penser tout bolt est
d'angers drake et dans toutes les
missions et en fait dans toute la saison
c'est seul moment où j'aime vraiment ce
qu'ils y pige cg une fois que ça ça
c'est rock et ça sort s'en était savoure
été réfléchie près le même si ça se
réfléchit en instantané le sais j'ai
c'est très très rare que je dis des
choses puisque ma faute j'aurais pas dû
dire c'est un fake
celui là c'est le seul moment où je
retournais chez nous tu es comme i way
c'est parce que tout le monde soit sur
qui est pour moi la sq était le plus
difficile c'est même pas par rapport à
un mois ou par rapport à s'était
littéralement parce que j'ai dans une
nouvelle relation en ce moment le puis
je me disais ouf est ce que ma belle
famille va me trouver intense magique
capable jouable d'autant que capables à
100% sauf que tj dodig il argumenté
mais quand tu es dans une nouvelle
relation le tout à coup est en coupe ccc
d'accepter aussi que ce kit impacts ont
épaté l'autre et vice versa thé et je
pense qu'on a quand même une
responsabilité quand on est en couple de
considérer l'autre puis ça me stresse un
petit peu parce que tu es patrick c'est
la personne la plus gentille bien
intentionnés se griller un coeur en or
they je me disais en main
est ce qu'il veut et je veux juste pas
qu'il se ramasse un peu de cette équipe
là ça sera forte moins stressé puis
après ça c'est sorti pu nettement
eh bien je dire je regarde pas beaucoup
les messages puis pas beaucoup sur mes
plates formes fait que ça se peut que ça
y est le gros tours bio puis je n'en ai
pas encore mais j'ai eu vraiment plus de
positif que de négatif est à par rapport
à celle je veux repartir sur ce que tu
viens juste de 10 par rapport à être
encore parce que si je trouve ça
intéressant tu dis qu'être en couple
c'est un peu prendre
en fait on peut réaliser que ce qui peut
être impacté pour impacter la personne
avec qui tu es
je sais pas je sais pas si je le vois
comme ça on dirait que dans mal dans ma
vision de comme une relation maintenant
c'est comme deux deux entités qui qui
évolua indépendant maintien puis que
mais en même temps j'imagine que t'as
pas le choix c'est atx et atx et de
faire quelque chose piquionne en pensant
à une autre personne n'a t-on je veux
que je m'exprime vraiment tout croche
tellement que ça ce que je trouve que
c'est vraiment ma vision des relations
changé beaucoup au fil des années puis
puis j'ai comme l'impression que
maintenant j'aimerais être avec
quelqu'un qui soit 100% libre d'évoluer
comme elle veut sans penser à
l'application que ça va avoir sur moi ou
sur ma femme et mes proches mes amis et
c'est vrai que résidera est ce que c'est
possible
est ce que c'est possible parce que
c'est une vision qui est qu'il est dit
est ce que on doit puis est-ce que même
si légitime de nous mêmes pensées sa
pensée mettons qu'on est en coupe metton
moi de dire moi c'est ça je voudrais
fait que je vais l'appliquer à ma propre
vie fait que je me connais un peu des
répercussions de ce que je vais faire
dans la dans la vue de l'autre personne
pour peu qu'il faut se qualifier de
réflexion je pense juste qu'il faut
faire il faut faire en sorte que les
deux personnes qui se trouvent
naturellement
les répercussions amérique tout est dit
des choix en fonction des choix et non
de la répercussion tu veux quand j'étais
encore le sait c'est que ça n'a pas
d'impact parce que ça devrait pas
modifier ton choix mais tout me suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec ce qu'est
ce que tu viens de dire dans ce sens
qu'il faudrait pas nécessairement que ça
modifie ton choix que c'est dans un idh
grrrr conscient de l'impact que ça va
avoir sur tous les sites a conscience de
l'impact que ça va avoir sur l'autre
personne son entourage modifie ton choix
mais je pense hélas qu'un problème ben
en fait c'est que je pense que ça serait
un signe qui a peut-être ces deux
personnes ne sont pas alignés ont été
sauf que je pense que c'est un peu
utopique de dire que tu pourrais être
dans une relation puis qui ait aucune
considération des impacts de ce que tu
fais sur l'autre personne qui le mange
et je sais comment un truc que tu
m'emmènes imprudence et station le pi et
moi je vois beaucoup les bleus ça va
tellement pas vraiment avoir eu du jeu
mais pas les chances de mon côté mais
mais je vois beaucoup les relations
comme un partnership d'affaires on la
regarde
mais comme les gîtes d'affaires pitt et
la pression va dire que la bbc comme la
vie commune genre avoir des enfants ou
ans que peu importe qui je pense que
quand tu es dans un partnership de
business avec quelqu'un tu es quand même
responsable des effets de ce que tu
décides mettons tout de même décidé de
partir
faire un rallye avec la meute dirigeants
tout le long ça se peut que ça fâche et
on pas le genre parce que vous avez une
business je sais pas - peu importe
maintenant pendant l'exemple concret du
studio ici ou est ce que donneront des
propriétaires du studio puis comme si je
vois un rallye que la main qu'ils ne
faisaient qu'une chaude la meute ça se
peut que le podcast le studio tout sauf
l'enclavé oui mais si tu fais c'est
l'état mental mais j'ai envie d'aller
faire râler que la mode parce que je
revendique la hausse des plats on n'est
pas l'ultra hypothétique n'est pas du
tout la réalité
mais si je suis avec la mort
j'ai appelé aussi ce qui fait je suis
rendu une place tout ce que je veux
aller faire ce est-ce que je mens
empêcherait à cause de répercussions que
cela reste surtout ça fait longtemps
qu'on serait plus et ça fait prendre
dans un matin je serais surpris c'est
celle qui en fait c'est qu'est à dien
fdd
si tout se faisait ce que tout ça ne
dérangeait pas tant ben les impacts dans
le fond vous les vivriers ensemble vous
serez les deux assez aligner pourrait
cup
il faut construction peut contenter mais
si toi tu étais 0 courant mail vous êtes
juste pour aligner dans le couple ou
dans le business par une chipie et je
pense que c'est simple je pense que dans
une nouvelle relation celle où ces
disciplines le genre vient à l'exemple
de tantôt c'est que tu connais pas
nécessairement l'autre l'autre personne
super bien d'autres personnes assez pour
savoir si est ce que cette personne
n'est capable de prendre ce huis clos
est ce que tu es dans le cas avec
patrick tj lui j'en ai parlé puis après
après l'émission jeter comme à emmen
qu'est-ce que tu parents vont penser
juste respecté commence tu savais ammar
avait dans le salon qui va être comme
yugo effecté la préfet était avance
tranquillement quitté capable de gadji
si le partnership fonctionne je pensais
en bout de ligne
si naturellement il ya peu trop de
compromis à faire parce que juste sa
flopée vous allez dans même direction
pédaler des valeurs semblables fine
métier c'est comme si c'est utopique de
penser car jamais aucun compromis nous
ou peut-être pas nécessairement de
compromis mais pas je pense aussi que
idéalement le moyen de compromis dans un
couple on vomit dans le ton le tic en
tulle des antilles le décortique s'est
toutefois faire de quoi que s'attendent
pas pour que moi précieuse face de quoi
qui me tente pas dans le fond gars tu le
vois moi même c'est de la merde un point
où c'est
je veux le faire juste un petit peu
moins que ça va me faire chier pitt ça
va être quand même un petit peu tout ça
vaut quand même te faire chier mais
c'est sûr qu'il y en a tout le temps un
petit peu mais je pense que règle d'or
le moins possible qu'ils épient mais le
sait la théorie des lignes parallèles
j'ai tout fait par là dessus podcast
souvent souvent je pense que ce parc se
trouvait maintenant tu veux trouver
quelqu'un que la trajectoire et
parallèle avec la tienne la plus proche
possible c'est parce que 1° mettons des
différences dans l'immédiat ces
présences offrait quatre dates de lines
a fait un test gap tu puisses intérêts
que je suis bien au courant mais que
j'ai à l'oubli très peu appliquée voilà
définitivement que j'applique plus je
veux
parler de ça avec toi parce que tout te
quitter pour une relation dans le fond
avant de partir à rodez c'est une
relation longue distance qui finalement
n'était acquis mois je m'en vais en
islande
ouais un an je laisse les affaires ici
son sens tant que si tu parles de lignes
parallèles jeunes qui traverse l'autre
bord pas mal loti et a failli jeter par
l'avant toit ni toi ni est ce que tu dis
qu'est ce que je leur ferai pas si
c'était à refaire on attend si
l'opportunité se présente encore fait
parce que c'est trop loin qui j'étais
avec ma trajectoire où tu dis ma
trajectoire manama m'en voyez là dessus
en fait j'ai géré ferait exactement tout
ce que j'ai fait dans cette relation le
mais ça me tenterait forking peau parce
que ça a été est la période la plus
difficile et sombre et répugnante de
toute ma vie si je savais dans bliss qui
m'attendait qu'il fallait que je le
refasse je partirai avec la salle
blanche si on gratte un peu le mal fond
c'était de ce que j'ai compris que je me
suis je me trompe c'est quelqu'un qui
faisait de la musique pendant deux ans
avant ce temps leur vous étiez
nn out lui venait ici tout c'est un tel
talent elle voit en tournée toute
l'équipe
puis l'agresseur a pendant un an de jack
et moi je veux vivre avec lui sert
autant on a va qui repartent en tournée
tu le quittes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
c'était si difficile qu'est ce qui est
arrivé
m comment faire une très longue histoire
courte et ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
est grand temps d'en suivre un million
de leçon de vie qui tourne encore en
train d'apprendre de ces moments là mais
en gros ce que s'est passé ce qui est
magique
j'ai une habitude d'être et à se
détacher dans mais dans mes relations et
j'ai une habitude d'être et d'avoir une
zone de confort qui est comme un petit
brin de distance puis d'avoir peut-être
une personne qui est un petit peu plus
dépendante de moi que moi je le suis de
l'autre personne et j'ai plein de patin
desquels je suis vraiment pas fier mais
qui grâce à ce que est ce que tu te
forces pour garder ses distances le pas
du tout non ça arrive sur farid hussein
tu sais pas où il est mais pendant c'est
pas l'indépendance mais je dirais que si
et si je pars je parle au passé parce
que je pense que depuis les dernières
années j'ai été capables de défaire si
ces mécanismes le mais je pense que
c'est un confort qui a longtemps été
bâti à travers l'inconfort de l'autre au
sens où plus l'autre personne sentait
que j'ai glissé entre les doigts puis
plus la personne s'attache à moi + moi
je me sentais cqp htc pour mes créations
vraiment dégueu puis j'en suis pas fier
pis la seule raison pour laquelle je
capable d'en parler maintenant c'est
parce que j'ai été capable de le voir
travailler ouest où le temps le premier
steps de ces deux là vous il met en
résulte est j'y fais de la peine à
beaucoup de monde j'ai fait de la penn
ar à défaut king bongo pas mal à tout le
monde avec qui j'étais tibet le gie poe
une ceinture non plus mais j'en ai eu
quand même cinq pièces était la même
dynamique dans toutes mes couple qui
dans celui là un plus humain dans
celui-là inclusivement puis celui là
dans le fond je pense que c'était la
première personne que je rencontrais qui
avait cessé nos dix suspects aux autres
les spas qui ce que l'on parle parle pas
français je pense qu'on est guillemets
mais c'était le premier qui avait je
pense que l'intelligence émotionnelle de
nicolas août sur ces choses là mais
clairement d'être comme le la en ce
moment tu étais pas ouverte
tu partages peu ta vie tes potes étaient
peu vulnérables dans le fond si pichichi
all in
mais toi tu es garde une porte de sortie
il y ait un moment donné c'est arrivé
juste arrivé devant un ultimatum aux
eskimos dit le pauvre et c'est soit tu
me laisses rentrée où je décolle et ses
pièges avaient jamais tu es quand je dis
assez loin piet comme dans toute bonne
histoire de coupe qui finit mal
ça a complètement changé la la dynamique
pilotes c'est la première fois qu'ils
ont goûté à la bombe c'est moins pillet
ça a été la chose la plus refus kg photo
réalisée ce que puisque pleine gueule
dans ton passé ont pu vivre de cette
espèce de dynamique là un peu et balancé
trois exactement puis le même genre
avait pigé à celle pour que quand ça
s'est fini le jeter s'il bat déjà plus
tout le monde peut être que je m'excuse
mais je sais que mes sérieux jean
sébastien le jeune accidenté sa mère
mais c'était ça est extrêmement rare pis
le bain ajoute à ceux en fait c'est que
le lui à ce moment les hits et comme le
jeu fait plus de compromis qui il va
falloir que tu vas falloir que tu
trouves que tu fasses tes propres
efforts ce sujet que ça fonctionne qui
l'a ce moment le lui avais l'opportunité
de retourner chez lui en cela faisait
quatre ans qui était en tournée puis il
s'ennuie de sa gamme s'ennuie de sa
famille puis nous on avait discuté de
peut-être qu'ils viennent à montréal
puis qu'on habite ensemble ici mais à
cause de ce que c'était par cette prise
de conscience l'est et comme tu es toi
de faire ton beau chapeau est plutôt
qu'ils venaient se sont donc grainger
love genou et j'aime ouvrir c'est
qu'eric italie piet bain dans le fond
elle ajoute à cette nouvelle dynamique
mais ajoute je parle pas la langue
mettons en islande ce poème dont je
comprends un peu je dois d'être
complètement différent dit viens me
rejoint de coin de fellering telle rue
je regarde mon film je sais pas encore
je regardais prononcer j'ai permis
travail là bas parce que parce que j'ai
pas le droit de travailler fait que peut
générer un une com et j'ai aucun ami et
il fait noir 24 sur 24
et c'était de la crise de marc mpay pib
en fait tu te demande ton existence est
quoi le filet puis btp si vous vous avez
fait de la musique compte que pour ceux
qui ont déjà fait de la musique et quand
tu pars en tournée survient et comme
imposteur dix prochains jo mme le quéau
c'est comme si tout est vraiment en 2010
parce que tu es tellement vécu des
émotions fortes qui est le tout à coup
on dirait que la vie normale est
vraiment bizarre avec lui passe à
travers la fête mais l'adrénaline lutte
que coûte à chaque soir après ce stade
il n'obtient qui s'est plu à se créer de
vide de recherche se scinde endorphines
qui pue la pente ou non de 6 comme tu es
ma vie c'est de la marne même en exergue
les missions dans les coteaux du jeu
tout en plein grand projet c'est quand
je serai plus en toile et je me bats
français je fasse finalement on se
retrouve les deux danseurs venant le
papillon nico hirtt effet que sa sagesse
était vraiment heures pour essayer si
c'est moi j'y pense à la mort la
sémantique
j'étais vraiment et j'avais plus j'avais
plus de repères j'étais vraiment ça
marchait pas puis j'y pense à travers
sais pas comment mais j'ai tellement
appris puis je
suis définitivement jeu fois king loin
d'être parfaite mais je suis vraiment
une meilleure personne de l'élue choi
qui c'est pour ça que je dis que j'ai
l'air est frais ça me tenterait fois
king peau mais je leur ferai part sur le
web parce qu'ils étaient sains important
je pense que je pense par lepage aurait
jamais pu avoir une vraie relation
100-106 garde l'absence d'automatismes
s'est répétée de ce moment le lui
quelqu'un qui te fait cet ultimatum le
est-ce que c'était une manière genre je
te dis que je mens je me sens et jupille
tu fais ce que tu es avec ce pseudo est
une manière un peu contre hollande
manipulatrice pour essayer d'avoir isolé
au site avoir eu mais à son grappin
je pense que j'ai je pense que j avais
déjà fait beaucoup trop de mal rendu là
pour que ça puisse à être saint ouen
pour que sa puce est ce un fait que je
pense que ces demandes à ce moment là
puis c'est tellement peu contre lui
parce que moi pour l'avoir vécu j'ai ça
peut choquer une personne ne
s'appelleront d'une personne qui part
avec des vraiment bonnes émotions
complètement mais je pense qu'à ce
moment là le mal était déjà fait mais
lui en me demandant ce qu'il fait pour
recevoir mes efforts comme avec des
bonnes intentions et on était juste
vouée à l'échec à ce moment là mais on
le savait peu plaideront on a juste fait
ressortir et le moins bon l'un de
l'autre et qui est qui et à ne pas
essayer à la maison et après un aspect
de la dombes du gaullisme c'est fou
comment que deux tu es une mauvaise
dynamique ou deux bonnes personnes
ça pulse un peu quand même tourné au
vinaigre
tipi donné quelque chose de vraiment à
l'ip de vraiment toxique que tout le
monde il est la situation de tellement
tellement tellement pis je l'aï vu moi
dans mes relations mais j'avais vu dans
les relations d'autres personnes 2,2
bonnes personnes les mains qui
deviennent que georges l'ombre d'eux
mêmes
c'est tellement important de choisir
une relation dans laquelle tu épanouie
un petit il s'est tout de suite je sais
pas pourquoi conques ont scandé des
causes de la mort con con con place
qu'on place au au dessus de tous les
sentiments
exact c'est si on en parle souvent ce
que l'amour ce n'est qu'une des affaires
à ça ce n'est qu'un des aspects pis ça
s'en va et ça vient et surtout ça mais
quand on est dedans on pense que c'est
unique que ça existe juste le moment
c'est quoi parce que non mais l'est-il
espèce de 6,6 et les papillons l'espèce
d'excitation de débuter ceux ci c'est un
mélange à peine affable chimiques pied
du stress là dedans puis une sorte
d'enfant estimé mais cet amour le tai
chi qui prend la place de tout le reste
qui prend la place de la lucidité et
bien-être c'est système de règles voit
ici clairement un truc c'est démontrer
même et scientifiquement peas et si ça
le tout les mêmes effets qu'une
addiction et un drop georges d'autres et
éthiques
soit 10 % travers même les pires moments
pour retrouver ce pour le trouver 7 et
pour avoir ton pour avoir trahi pythie
jeudi deux personnes qui plonge ans
plancher de la cuisine complètement
d'école s'est elle aussi se doter que
benfica neil cotty le plus laid que ça
peut pas rester ça peut pas durer dans
le temps à moins que la relation soit
toxique pillay respect des difficultés
qu'ils ont on voit dans un beau procès
ni un gros achat toujours pendante à non
plus et sa fille surtout des centres
détruire messi tandis que je te lèves le
matin que je pense que personne n'était
facile tout ça cool c'est le foie les
projets ensemble c'est parce que ça on
le valorise pas assez
je pense qu'ils ont le valorise
peut-être juste après avoir vécu l'autre
genre d'amour parce que c'est lui écoute
c'est tellement glamour us cet amour
passionnel c'est dans les films petite
pique à papy les deux qui comble la fiv
a manqué son avion pilotes y arrive à la
rue pops minimes 1 les véhicules en
vraie ville c'était soufflante à
brackley temps quand il applique à la
vraie vie ça sonne comme un cauchemar
c'est genre tabernacle avion partant
mais jerry fait pas que de riez gélif
est pauvre et le roi ou le mont volcan
s'est librement depuis j'ai dépensé le
il ya une année jusqu'en 2018 j'ai des
mois j'ai dépensé au dessus de 10000
pias un fred d'avion de trucs mans qui
en se lâcher quand c'est la scion des
doutes et elle parce qu'on s'était
chicane et puis il fallait qu'on passe
le jour de l'ensemble à l'ensemble deux
jours avant le jour de l'an ça coûte 1
est breux mais tu es dans un film d'ici
dont romantique s'asseoir aussi
passionné lpi team mais il faut que
celle vécue le dit et on se prend ce
comme trois semaines d'avancé pourront
reprendre le biais moins cher dit
souvent mieux dormir chez nous ça va on
fait toujours de l'avant et ayant un
regard avion ça serait pas chicaner la
veille qui est terry consigne un prévenu
de la nuit pisser garde non leur menu a
pas dormi que ça m'arrive je sais que
c'est pourquoi elle était d'enfoncer
d'offres c'est juste des chicanes le
tilt et des chicanes qui ça crie ça
pleure ceux ci moi je pense même pas que
je pense que c'est normal je pense que
c'est normal intégration je pense que
c'est normal d'avoir type ia pression de
boujan par les fautes me dire oui mais
non c'était ça arrive un tome et janry
mama le drame a dit le ton par je peux
compter ses doigts d'une main le nombre
de fois qu'on s'est chicané qui
ces cct des mises au point des
discussions où est-ce qu'on est ouvert
aux conditions tournant c'est de pas
tomber trop d'apprendre des trucs
personnels tomber dans l'émotivité ou
tomber d'un genre oui encore mise au
point c'est sûr mais des chicanes
d'inscrits après on pleure pilon on
passe proche de se laisser on revient à
sable ce no god no run and gun buizingen
au burundi c'est que tout le monde a
vécu ses relations avec sédation la
pensant que c'est quand même que c'est
vraiment plus on s'aime tellement puis
on va passer au travail non non ça
marche
puis c'est drôle mais puisque ça doit
tellement cool d'avoir un modèle comme
ça aussi c'est parce que mogi moi j'ai
pas vu que savoir départ ensemble c'est
une peu me donné des des trucs de
relation mais quand j'ai la chance de
rencontrer un couple qui durait depuis
des décennies le comme ça car en termes
je disais incroyable et je les pose ces
questions le parce que j'en ai peu de
temps dans mon entourage et des gens qui
ont réussi à vivre ce qui mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment inscrit
dans une belle stabilité puis dans un -
dans un équilibre seroquel ils sont six
à épiler l'eau sont nous qui mène faux
valeurs et normes live moi je pense que
c'est ancré dans une génération c'est
longue relation de moi je pense
honnêtement que ça se peut plus vraiment
ou du moins si ça se fait ultra hors des
relations qui mettons de notre
génération vont durer 40 ans et je pense
en fait je pense pas que c'est même
envisageable mais ton site citons
réflexe est de voir mes tontons que
j'aime ta blonde comme étant la personne
de ta vie je pense pas que c'est le bon
réflexe je pense que le réflexe est de
voir la personne comme étant la personne
qui est bonne pour toi à ce moment là
puis de rythme au titre d'une amoureuse
stable
holy shit
oui mais je pense qu'il faut normaliser
aussi les relations qui se termine mais
qui sont un succès quand même c'est
parce que je pense que c'est ce qu'on
réalise de plus en plus le tien mais ton
de dire aussi y ont eut ils ont eu un
enfant sont séparés après cinq ans c'est
pas un échec relationnel vous avez quand
même qu'on trouve quelque chose puisse
arriver à sa fin et puis moi je trouve
ça correct que je pense que j'aime et
rationnellement et ça arrivera plus des
40 ans comme seul le vrai échec bt c'est
que ça vaut tout le temps ça continue
pour que ça finisse à prélever chèque
c'est de rester 10 ha dans quelque chose
qui est personnelle elle s'est réveillée
un matin puis charger qu'est ce que je
fais ici je suis pas bien je pas urgent
parce qu'il aurait voulu être
j'ai fait trop de compromis ne sais pas
c'est ce serait à chaque facture aux
haïti minustah mes parents ils se
séparaient demain matin et puis je serai
genre good job toutefois kingdom pièces
et des fois tu t'es plus plus plus ça
fait longtemps aussi plus de fois quand
ça va mal foutu tough un but parce que
ça les salles de bain était parrainé
stib août parce que ça revienne
ça serait triple jeu revient au galop
avec momo grand romantisme mais c'est
sion en fait un parallèle avec justement
là le business partner chez moi je suis
dit on regarde et on regardé par rapport
aux carrières se rendent vraiment rares
les gens qui ont la même job pendant 40
ans le pigeon
on se donne le droit de se réinventer
d'essayer autre chose puis de retourner
à l'école puis d'apprendre un nouveau
succès et ce alors qu'ils étirent on
recule
une ou deux générations avant d'étudier
une fois pour être jugé pour - jean
cordonnier mais ce business a été fait
que je pense que peut-être que c'est la
même chose avec les relations que on se
donne neuf droit d'avoir plusieurs
villes de se réinventer d'essayer des
différentes choses je pense que c'est
vrai ce que tu dis que la personne qui
me convient maintenant peut-être combien
de repas à qui je vais à être dans ses
120 ans sexta croissance personnelle
puisque puis ton évolution
ce fait à l'extérieur de ton groupe
parce que moi je pense que ça doit wii
se faire aussi avec la personne avait
quitté en cours mais principalement toit
en verre toi même si cette évolution le
sujet tout envers toi même quand les
tétées rendu trop loin du couple puis
j'aime vraiment ton parallèle avec les
job parce que c'est aussi générationnel
comme personne cdt parents en tête ont
paru la même job pendant les quarante
ans que ta mère lui même chose avec mes
parents - même chose pour tout le monde
qu'on connaît qui rentrent à job à 18
ans puis qui prennent leur retraite
qu'ils ont été hantées djabla ça
arriverait justice ou très peu comme les
couples qui durent quarante ans et fait
que je sais pas à quoi on peut attribuer
sa méthode sais tu vraiment parce qu'on
a une meilleure connaissance de nous
mêmes pays qu'on est capable de réaliser
que le sens me convient plus est ce que
c'est parce qu'on abandonne trop tôt est
ce que c'est parce que on est trop
attirés par la nouveauté à cause de de
l'impact des notes c'est l'horaire de la
nouvelle rapide c'est quoi tisser son
ensemble de toutes ces choses je pense
que c'est plus positif que négatif les
années qui vont dire que votre
génération justement vous travaillez pas
ses affaires vous abandonnez vous
changer moi je vois ce possible jouer
que on tique plus des trucs avec
lesquels qu'on n'est pas bien compris
qu'on connaît un conte point fr
j'aimerais tellement fait d'accord avec
toi mais en bon avocat du diable
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient le mal
être de notre génération et comme of the
child par rapport aux générations
précédentes qui peut-être que ce parce
qu'avant on se l'avouer peu mais si on
se connaît assez bien c'est vrai qu'on
compte c'est qu'on décide de pu prendre
le chip qu'on veut avec lequel on veut
pas dit l'état mettons qu'on se dire
qu'ils aiment ou cette jupe bleu semble
qu'on impute aux rebelles
on devrait être plus heureux font
serment t mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
lit pas nécessairement
je me demande si cette stabilité cette
encre âge le auquel on aux forces et en
fait je m'en dit si à un certain moment
donné ça fait qu'on est un peu plus
grande dit je sais pas je pense que
l'être humain est on ne plus réfléchir à
voix haute je suis loin d'être un
spécialiste mais j'aime vraiment la
conversation qu'ont ans mamadou et je me
demande si l'être humain on n'a pas
besoin de se définir tu es incapable de
se définir simplement si mettons mettons
jeune membre encore une fois quelqu'un
la génération de nos parents
qu'est ce que tu fais cette personne va
te dire à moi je suis électricien
d'accepter puis j'ai comme le feeling
est inadéquat qu'est ce que tu fais tu
savais c'est tellement drôle parce que
je l'aï vécu cette situation le
justement avec l'extra question où est
ce que je l'aï mangé dans sa famille qui
était commentée puis qu'est ce que tu
fais pipi mais la panique qui s'est
emparée de moi et j'ai lancé
sérieusement je ne sais jamais quoi dire
à cette pige jusqu'à aujourd'hui le
puits les courtes parties dans ma vie ou
juillet où j'ai eu comme un emploi tbj
juillet ça m'a tellement fait du guide
et des fous je reste dans jobs juste
pour ça j'espère moi je suis directrice
de projet à tous les gestionnaires de
projet vous aimez tant chez hays et
cordoue stratégie lg2 les petits gars de
la conversation c'est fini le ps a fait
cette ville qui mais est ce que je t'ai
aussi bien dans ce que je fais et au
quotidien probablement moins sûr que
tout est bien parce que tout d'abord de
delphine et simplement
c'est seulement maintenant le je prends
mon exemple que moi j'ai fait de la
natation de compétition pendant
longtemps albert steppiques à j'ai fini
ma carrière je de 5,1 jusqu'à 26 le
monde ballack est fait je vous ai je
suis chez la natation la cité se faisait
l'école était sûr on va peut-être on la
faisait ça que je me définis le définir
quand ça finit
moi ça ça a été une période qui a été
top
ce que j'avais plus j'avais pu ça du
tout faites là on est parti nous au 33
ensemble après ce jeu tu as l'air ou des
blocages sortie daudet c'était décuple
il sait qu est ce que tu fais mm je sais
pas qu'est ce que je fais je ne crois
pas à dire je n'expose il ou non ces
gens je me cache partout la caisse je
fais des photos de maillots de bain mais
l'asnl après les filles nous ouvre son
cas fait factice et s'appuie la pression
c'est quand tu sais pas je crois je
pense que je suis pasqua puis le cadre
défini vient malaise un mal à être
complet de pas être capable de mettre le
doigt sur c'est quoi je fais ma
direction c'est là qu'elle le tue puis
jusqu'à ce que on commence le podcast le
studio que l'achat ce qui peut
entreprenons pas de castor est à cannes
2010 loth depuis quand le monde me parle
ce qui se fait dans vip le chaikin magie
est une business on fait des podcasts et
bien je sais qu'un crise inquiète c'est
vrai d'un fonds estime bercy
mais je pense que de quoi aussi kiki qui
marche dans on a besoin d'avoir un
certain confort je pense que même si
justement l'idée de genre qui est pour
une journée qui ressemble à l'autre puis
nana na na na c'est comme encore une
fois dramatiser puis ça l'a vraiment à
baulmes intime moi même si ça ça fait
dix ans à travers un homme qui défend
sert à flirter avoir genre jamais savoir
qu'elle soit faire dans un biopic de
calendrier v est pilotée comme crier ce
ch'ti pigeât qui était justement le
modèle le modèle bourré avoirs de la
famille ne sait peut-être que même si ma
grand mère elle a peut-être eu le choix
entre trois bonhommes ce bonhomme leurs
familles avait peut-être une fois dedans
l'utilisant enfante la mode et de cette
fillette est habité le tueur trouver un
certain bonheur là dedans même c'était
peut-être pour ton rêve est accompli de
grandes choses elle voulait accomplir
mais il ya un bonheur aussi dangereuse
de ville
stable avec des gens que des enfants
affectés
c'est sûr que ça fait penser c'est comme
quand tu veux au resto gens qui cassent
un resto dynamics qui est allié avec des
sushis gens il faut que je prends mais
il ya quand même un certain confort à ce
que ta belle province peter joies de
l'été ya aussi aimé ta g a choisi la
piscine pierre roquet la plus totale
reste à ma vie pouvait la seule à fat
veut commander chez vous c'était
saint-hubert maintenant tu ouvres ton
fils ton hubert ripd tous les restos du
monde antique la magie pas parce que
j'arrête c'est halo netflix dans les
séries comme tel et de la vase et
choisissez comme la crise lire entre
11h30 et je me couchais qu on avait
super écran le mégarde peut pas le choix
il y avait trop film space de dire je
n'ai à sa tête et coups durs je dis pas
que c'est mieux mais je veux juste dire
qu'est l'absence de choix des fois ça
fait que tu es content je pense que
c'est ce qui se passe avec les
générations avant pitel et peu mon
endroit camara s'est jamais dit à mes
yeux il ya plein de rêves que je voulais
accomplir c'est exactement cette apple
missing out puis tu regardes peut-être
que les deux s'équivalent il ya du bon
et du mauvais dans les deux côtés mais
je veux revenir à quelque chose que tu
as dis parce que ça me fait rire à quel
point
quand j'ai fait l'émission justement non
volvo j'ai eu c'était quelque chose qui
était super important pour moi je
partais avec qui avec sept joueurs de
conviction le et je trouve qu'on définit
beaucoup beaucoup les gens de par ce
qu'ils font envie viacom 3 donné le
ch'ti qu'est-ce qui fait envie
de quel âge qui est ce que l'on te c'est
pas mal ces deux le nom je vous donne un
bon troisième inscrit peu importe qui
dans le fond on s'est placé leur ton nom
ton âge peut-on emploi oui tu en entends
h en emploi qui doit être marquée pour
toi mais je voulais pas mettre d'emplois
puis j'ai pas mis d'argent sale mais je
trouve que surtout dans un contexte
comme sa pression dans la vraie vie des
fois c'est moins applicable mais je
trouve qu on se donne la chance de
connaître les gens sensés donner le on
apprend des affaires qu'on aurait
probablement on serait peut-être jamais
rendu le thé six mois
demain les temps sont durs pige book
pupilles et fayyoum et met dehors puis
en tout cas peu importe je décide
d'aller travailler au service à la
clientèle chez vidéotron bell chute
encore vraiment la même personne c'est
qu'on a de legrand qu'on me demande
qu'est ce tu fais bien traversé l'année
sa clientèle chiffres du tronc ben c'est
pas qui je suis et serai chez moi nous
avons une personne non au moins ou plus
ou taissy
je trouve juste que ça prend beaucoup de
place dans la dans l'identité et
étrangers avec l'âge parce que moi à 40
ans n ont même pas moi à 20 ans j'étais
beaucoup moins matures et adultes qui
est non mois à 40 ans beaucoup moins
adultes immatures qui mettons un pacte à
20h savent le gap va toujours être le
pain portent nos acheter si ça c'est
tout ça c'est vrai
c'est fascinant que si on est important
de se poser des questions là je pense en
tant que notre génération de se masquer
toutes les conversations que j'ai avec
des gens qui ont un travail je suis
comme tout le temps tout le temps un peu
dans le questionne un questionnement de
ckoi ma foi king place parce qu'on
dirait qu'on est comme dans un espèce de
sanou et chantre nos parents puis qui
s'en vient après placé que moi mais moi
je me reconnais un peu plus locle au
pilote mais en même temps je reconnais
là aussi c'est sûr plein d'enfants fait
c'est si touch est quand même bien je
sais pas si c'était comme ça tout le
temps c'est pas ça a toujours été comme
ça je pense y mettons toutes les
générations sont retrouvés en et un
sandwich au milieu de 2,2 des hauts de
deux idées pis un pote trop sachant pas
trop savoir où est sa place tu fais pas
ça a toujours été ce sens qu'il le monde
l'histoire avance de plus en plus
rapidement ces méthodes tenais à 12 115
ou moins 12 175
je pense que le monde je pense que la
vie de ton peuple te des enfants vont se
ressembler quand même sur des fermiers
qui faisait chier dessus par la loi la
royauté du très chic cheval à royan
saintes radiateur
le contexte dans lequel on grandit
versus nos parts à versus juste les
laitiers liquides qui sont nés en 2001
ne trie on dirait que c'est comme un
monde de différence le tipi puis on le
tue sorte d'angoissé nos parents je
pense pas mes parents à 30 ans il était
vraiment préoccupés par les changements
climatiques mais ton mais le sait comme
une réalité convient tout avec l'espèce
dans ghost le des caisses qui va arriver
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est le foot je
composte pis dans la lentille tandis que
c'est sûr je pense que pile et les
technologiques changé plus en plus
rapidement le tir mais ton jeu pendant
une génération c'est comme dans leur vie
a eu la radio au charme et on sait pas
c'est quand même ça chaque année il ya
une chose qu'il a voulu sionnel comment
qu'on fonctionne fait que moi quand
j'étais enfant il y avait pas d internet
juste des fois je repense à seul mot que
je me posais une question danville
fallait jaya bibliothèque pour chercher
la réponse de google
je dis je des femmes et enfants il va
être comme moi des deux coaches phoque
genre quelle est la capitale de la
falaise à la bibiothèque emprunté à
brancher sur google a en tout temps wad
j'abonde dans ton sens c'est sûr qu'ils
étaient de ce regard-là coeur pur que
c'est je pense définitivement qui est
que les questions se multiplient à la
vitesse de l'éclair ou comme réentendre
un peu à vivre chacun tellement tout
change mais comme un boulet sa matrice
qui est juste le monde et si en 2019
versus le c'est comme on veut quand même
réalité exacte
c'est probablement seul des heures ou du
moins le
l'idée mettant dans mon dans mon for
intérieur je
on dirait que j'ai juste envie que ça
ralentit ce que ça arrête
c'est comme ça mon feeling total géré au
quotidien le ccac risques puis
dernièrement j'ai commencé à prendre des
week-end complet de genre de mode avion
de juste arrêter le truc puis maintenant
que je souhaite à ce qu'on dit le on
dirait crise que ses seules en vie on
dirait que c'est comme le ça va
tellement vite je veux juste ça si je
suis inquiet c'est exactement les prises
de conscience que j'ai eues j'étais je
disais ça avec ma psy que j'ai là j'ai
tout le temps mais j'ai cette sensation
lieu de toujours était pas à la hauteur
parce que je me dis tout le temps mais
je vais prendre un break mais que j'ai
fini tu veux juste finir surtout d'où le
petit mec ça soit faite je veux relaxe
et la fin il finit jamais je n'ai jamais
jamais allait bien et qu'on voit
réglisse se séparaient fait que ça fait
juste ça fait juste s'ajouter puis ça
fait ça fait deux semaines que j'ai
commencé à faire sa mesure effectivement
j'avance plus je rattrape mon retard et
je prends pas de la vence j'ai fait
fauconnerie
je fais mon lavage je fais mes affaires
normal de vie je veux voir mes amis qui
ça fait deux semaines que j'ai faits
puis la tentation et ai été vraiment dur
le pas ce que veut que j'ai c'est que
l''indice avec plus rester mais je pense
que c'est important d
je pense que c'est important de la faire
cette coupure le parce que sinon moi ce
que ça fait c'est j'aime j'ai pu exister
de ma vie tu es jeune est juste une
incurie je venais comme ça s'arrête
jamais dû cesser d'être candidate pas
envie de rentrer dedans
exact exact retard et dans une étude du
genre de saturation des strass chose à
ford chose dans ton cerveau c'est comme
mais si c'était plaisir à rien petit
juste et juste pour de justes pas
agréable juste j'étais plus jeune encore
potence gagnante car je n'en sais rien
c'est drôle parce que la prof atomique
et j'ai fait ça c'est un phénomène de
mafate je suis parti avec deux de mes
meilleurs amis qui en a une qui m'a dit
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment vraiment
fait réaliser ce hadith et [ __ ] cool
est dans le jus non tu es je pense que
ça a été vraiment vraiment valorisé
l'éthique on se disait hp le projet le
jeu contre julie cet ancien mansaré de
paul
mais ce fut ce t je pense que l'heure où
le retour du balancier est en train de
se faire c'est ce qu'est ce qui coule
c'est d'être enfin que tes amis partent
et monuments d'avoir du temps pour aller
à hay qui pillent et d'y prendre son
temps quand je vous félicite et des
affaires simples et je pense qu' on
revient un petit peu marre c'était moi
j'veux pas rendu mais ce que j'entends
dans le fond c'est vrai typique mais il
ya un des enjeux aussi dans tout ça
c'est que tu le vois maintenant
maintenant avec la crise du logement
c'est que si t'es pas en mode fois king
travail intense bonne chance en tabarnak
pour te permettre d'avoir un chalet qui
permet des chapitres exact fait que ces
gens qui met par world brand sont exacts
mais ton monsieur me dis je je voudrais
m'acheter une propriété un chalet dans
les laurentides
ok guide c'est bon je tends une somme
toute un bon concept mais tabarnak sur
genre le studio puis tout plein de
projets pour être capable de me dire à
qui non là je vais aller m'acheter un
chalet cp à des prix plus possible
tout le monde achète des trucs 1.5
millions un peu partout le titre qui met
du temps où je prends sur la réponse est
que moi mais ça coûte 20 pièces pour un
terrain de camping
oui mais tu être ma relaxe car faire des
jeux le feu le plus sexy que si on nous
vend un rêve et comme pipo temps
accessible c'est celle de vente ont
chassé comme un mythe genre de conneries
mais pas par où je prends ce petit
jeu-là correct ou la balance je pense
que c'est ça aussi c'est que on je
l'entend beaucoup les je voyais je
voyais justement je me rappelle plus
trop quoi mais qui disait il ya comme la
peur de manquer des opportunités de têtu
dit mais si je ne fais pas tout de suite
mais le ch vraiment jus mais si je la
prends pas cette chance là peut-être que
demain je le répète ce revenu le août et
de vouloir vraiment battre le fer
pendant qu'il est chaud
je pensais la même chose dans n'importe
quel contexte professionnel team quand
je travaillais en agence c'était la même
chose c'est come back à j'avoue que le
ch vraiment plein cette semaine mais si
on le prend pas contre le rival à
l'otage ans puis on en a besoin de ces
revenus le parce que les temps sont durs
fait qu'il ya vraiment ce c'est la
lignée est vraiment minces
je pense que la courbe des mets ton
argent que je fais versus mais ton
sacrifice que je dois faire un genre ou
comme valeurs que je vois bendaoud
souhaite pas décemment toujours vrai le
tir de ces corrélations leurs tiges de
ton je pense à une amicale business avec
une autre vérité sont de fait pile celle
son talent au moment où est-ce qu'ils
engageaient des nouveaux employés qui
grossissent et leur business plus il y
en a une qui dit à l'autre c'est moi
juste pour mettre au clair je peux
comprendre qu'on est une grosse affaire
a piqué ont fait un million par année et
puis quand on travaille tout le temps
puis le lot de mehdi ben si je fais oui
mais ça veut pas dire que en bout de
ligne ce fait un million par année ça
veut nécessairement dire que ce trail
tout le temps tu es malheureux puisque
j'ai en tête avant tout aux normes ce et
je pense qu'il faut juste à l'ombre de
huy que tu fasses peau
c'est ça qui fait cela mais en bout de
ligne que tu fasses plus ou moins moi
j'aime vraiment mieux enfin moins
d'argent mais genre c est faire une
chose que j'aime puis genre justement
pas avoir l'impression que je donne mes
valeurs mais si je fais ce pic sera un
bon salaire en même temps c'est sur
l'argent et paul niveau l'argent pour
l'indicateur ça ramène ses souffre est
sûr que souvent mais je comprends
surtout les assure que souvent l'un va
avec l'autre camp dans la grande
majorité du temps d'étude monsieur lévy
q quand j'ai quand je sortais de
voldemort l'elysée d'aider les
opportunités promotionnelles ça a été
vraiment comme me le cash des jeunes
j'étais vraiment je t'ai pas mais on
était mme amara talus de la misère phi
phi je devrais j toujours manger lemay
mais c'était vraiment peu facile qui moi
quand je sors typiques comme free un
montant que pour moi je me souviens ce
que ça représentait quand j'étais petit
le montage de mesurer le démontage des
mesures il de me dire genre à qui je le
ferai pas parce que soit sa fait pas
avec mes valeurs ou les gens ni trop le
pij pub un pige dort peu c'est c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment top il fallait
que je fasse dès le début parce que j'ai
les bulls la pente avec glissante le si
je commence je serai pu vous arrêter
fait que fait que j'ai fait deux fois je
me suis dit je peux je peux je peux mais
c'est vraiment top je pense que c'est
cela c'est d'être capable d'évaluer le
tri dof par rapport à l'argent
c'est comme combien que je sacrifie dans
mon bien-être pour ce montant le pic est
ce que ça vaut
je pense que ça s'est vraiment off c'est
un exercice qui est extrêmement
difficile à faire de compromis possible
plus meilleur pays offre possible mais
cette balance le est incroyablement
finaux cissé qui tellement si des
petites affaires qui vont de façon
insidieuse nermine et on tombe bien être
c'est parce que tu t'es des voix si tant
d'argent pour une publication au final
jam easy money c'est que moi dans le
fond l'exacte puis côté puis j'apprécie
pour la question pour de vrai parlant
des deux contre un bout contre ux ans
bientôt d'animation de chou oui ces
fictions oui je m'en servais la fosse et
l'île de l'amour ou à ceux qui nous
écoutent qui savent que je mette
l'animatrice lui souhaite la dgid stampe
devant le monde de l'amour ouais j'ai
tout fait comme ça mais je vais arriver
dans le fond et je suis paumé ouvrir
jusqu'à maintenant ce que c'est ce que
j'attends quelqu'un qui m'appelle
optimise obs on pensait que c'était
dirigé coup sûr vu les mauvais non mais
j'ai écouté mon me vois le courriel pour
me dit on cherche quelqu'un pour ce
projet le et sa tante dci
c'est une audition offert trilogie j'ai
fait des tests car dangereux ou est ce
que j'avais comme peu de mises en scène
sont mais j'avais des tables houleux
avec avec des textes et tout ce qui est
dit écoute je sais pas comment mais j'ai
eu lieu
j comme vraiment pas pensé en fait eu
comme deux étapes une première où j'ai
fait un test car on me dit ça s'est
super bien passé ce qui est en train
d'en faire un autre
j'en ai fait un autre mais de rosheim je
déconne mais non non je fais et je
faisais ma vie puis éventuellement bon
après-midi b et quand on est vraiment
content de te dire que c'est toi qu'on
ait choisi pipi avec sommes pas d'autre
option si ce n'était vraiment pas besoin
on voulait juste sa stricte et est
capable de le faire maintenant je pense
qu'ils ont passé d'autres membres dans
l'est dans la première étape puis après
ceux à la deuxième étape il voulait
vraiment juste s'assurer que j'étais
capable de voir pas ce pauvre et j'ai
jamais fait qu'il voulait tester si
j'étais quand même souvenir de des
textes cas pas d'improviser cij avait de
l'empathie c'est mieux mais qui effectue
ce qui est écoutée bg jeu
je m'embarque là dedans vous ça nous ça
commence le tournage
ouais il me semble que c'est sûr ça va
être dur dans le fond c'est un
compétiteur direct daudet si je le vois
comme si je comprends bien c'est vrai
dans la même saison le serbe même temps
en fait c'est qu'elle est aussi avec les
avec la quevillais des taux et des
horaires de tournage qui ont été qui ont
été déplacés et et je pense que si je me
trompe popian preuve je parle on
comptera vraiment chapeau mais je pense
que ça avait été prévu que ça sorte à 20
que ça tourne avant d'ailleurs au
printemps finalement c'est avec les
mesures gouvernementales et où se
battent il fallut que tout le monde
s'ajuste mai mais oui c'est sûr que ça
va sortir à la rentrée après compétiteur
je sais pas si je vois ça comme de la
compétition parce que si on n'y a pas de
loi qui pourrait coûter que c'est moi
qui vous pouvez voir écouter les deux
parce que oui pis si c'est bon
légèrement l'écouté puis 6 pas bon les
gens l' écouteront pop je pense que ceci
dit y'a pas de quoi de corrélation
directement avec avec audi je pense que
la place pour tout le monde qui est
voilà je me doute que tu peux pas
répondre à cette question mais je
connais la pause et qui mesurait je peux
pas répondre
contractuellement te déteste contrat
avec produit encore pour tout en haut
des piles au dessus est ce qu'il ya un
enjeu à ce niveau là on you boys band
tout qu'est ce que j'ai le droit de dire
je m'en souviens pas je peux te dire que
j'étais pas et j'étais pas je pense qu'à
ce point si on sans but le jeu l'est
déjà du pis de façon il peut ne me fais
pas ci contre avec produit parce que
avant d'aller à rodez et avait négocié
sur pour nos progrès mais je vais parce
que c'est capital à rodez c'est eux qui
sont venus chercher toi ouais pas tous
capitule moi j'ai pas eh ben je
connaissais pas du tout les noms moi je
me suis pas inscrit après à la défense
de la presse de tous ceux et celles ci
j'avais peur ils m'ont quand même
rencontré simon a plaidé cette entrée
dessus tout c'est un militant 23h59
l'instant est rendu proche je sais je ne
saurai jamais patrick ewing s'était
désisté ou ans que je ne sais pas
montrer mon appli puis ils m'ont
rencontré quand même puis si ça avait
profité il m'aurait pris le fait que des
pots et non et oui sauf que tu avais
quand même le bout du bâton pour
négocier de la foire et moi je le fais
pas ci il faut que choi aux autres
pendant je sais pas quand même temps je
pense qu est ce qui fait la différence
c'est que ça a la base je le dis en
rétrospective je suis vraiment content
de l'avoir fait au défi je pense
vraiment que c'est une expérience qui
espéreraient enrichissante mais à ce
moment là dans ma vie j'étais fou king
pas sûr que ça me tente et maintenant je
pense qu'il ya eu ce qui a joué aussi
il y avait quand même le risque quand il
fait beau dit il ya toujours un risque
que tout ça peut être bénéfique ça peut
être
crissement négatif aussi et puis c'est
ma vie à l'aller somme toute quand même
bien et j'étais vraiment satisfaite dans
mes enfants que j'ai comme a été
pourquoi je m'en veux me mettre sous les
pointes c'est ça me tente pas
nécessairement de m'exposer à ce qui
était tout s'effondre qui à cause de
tout
j'étais quand même assez intransigeante
et par rapport aux contrôles m'acheter
comme mbaye mois au pire non ça marche
pas c'est ça c'est un amalgame est le
gros bout de la négoce et ça marche
comme là bas mais j'en voulais juste
pour moi on se fixer éventuellement
et éventuellement j'en ai juste pas eu
puis fait que ce fait que magie pas ce
n'est même pas de droits d'utilisation
de l'image de rien signé par tous belle
était même pas si je peux pas ce pauvre
et odéon était vraiment correct mon
effectif je veux vraiment pas dire des
informations qui seraient maintenant le
droit de saisir l'image que tu le
soulignes lorsqu'il faut que tu leur
laisses le droit de suite en image
exacte mais après je sais pas si tu es
comment pour toi dans ton animé ya plus
qu'un contrôle c'était un contrat pour
l'émission après ces rencontres des
représentations nous n'allons jamais sur
eux-mêmes pour une autre année à bâle il
avait pris l'homme est implémenté après
cessé avec maintenant que je pense que
c'est pas nécessairement s'est créé mes
yeux un contre pour l'émission et puis
après c'est un contrat pour la suite
d'amplifier la la carrière envers
d'influenceurs qui suit moi je savais
être d'emblée que je voulais pas
influencer personne mais ai dit que ça
m'intéressait vraiment peu vécu je leur
ai dit et jarry j'étais vraiment kg
dimanche je veux pas de contrat puis
vous perdrez pas de sous avec moi parce
que même si vous me signé jean vigo des
leggings effet que ces quais advienne
fdd baisse a fait que j'avais pas
d'attachés avec les productions j ai
fait que ça c'est sûr que ça a facilité
le truc mais eux le savaient pas quand
ils m'ont contacté le suscitée par une
information qui fait que je pense qu'ils
se seraient peut-être entendu à la
normale je sais pas parlant devant des
légumes oui je t'écoute et sur le
podcast avec qui arrive ce que tu
parlais de fait une parodie des
influenceurs sur ton instagram puis je
sais comme tel je suis pas seul je veux
parler mais j'aimais l'idée que je
disais que quand je trouve de quoi dole
gens rire c'est une peu importe c'est
quoi peu importe sa voix fut ce que des
gens se trouvent quelque chose de drôle
joue en rien puis site s'étoffe phare se
dire ceux en ce moment surtout sur une
plateforme qui est grosse comme comme la
tienne comme la mienne mettons le t2
devraient là je reprends mon seul puis
je regardais quelque chose sachant très
bien que je vois
alors tu es des gens au passage où papa
si possible à ma portée mais mettons
froisser des gens au passage moi comment
tu commentes huvier que c'est quoi ton
mindset mais tant qu'anti fait qu'il
doit faire ça parce que je trouve ça
juste drôle
puis ils vont un bâclage probablement
mêmes termes en coulisses plusieurs
choses et c'est un sujet qui tellement
épique tellement est important et
d'actualité aussi vraiment d'actualité
il ya deux choses par rapport à cette
genre de partie et j'arrivais vraiment
de nulle part dans ce sens que je parle
aux personnes qui influencent et je
connais pas cet univers le puits quand
j'ai fait ce truc là c'était tellement
que j'avais de magnitude dans mon truc
j'avais vu des choses passées puis tu
vas pas que ce soit un statement j'avais
aucune dès que je savais même pas qui à
ce moment là les y avait des
influenceurs qui se faisait lyncher pour
les affaires de voyage est est vraiment
le la fille qui sait peut pas toutes
pièces des bleus mais je fais ça parce
que je trouve ça très drôle parce que je
vois tes poches des chiffres exacts
puis je trouve que la façon que j'ai
fait c'est tellement clairement exagéré
évidemment que je parle pas de la
totalité des gens qui font ça et déjà
qu'ils qui promouvoit j'ai jamais
comment le conjuguer promouvoir des
services d
des objets peu importe que c'est super
intéressant ça fait avec moi je me
considère dans ce matin je fais de la
course à pied j'entends cours du
marathon que j'ai une commande et à new
balance pour les kicks de course tu sais
comme moi je me considère la dame est
tombée que je me que je me flatte et
inutilement le mais je m'étais entre eux
et wii puis même si moi je tombe sur un
projet dire comme avant les cas il y
avait 500 personnes qui me suivent et
c'était la même enfer je dire si je
tombe sur quelque chose que je trouve
cool ça se produit elle partage c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai trouvé qu'il a pu
mais c'est la première fois au monde
c'est ben gvir exacte et m
fait que j'ai absolument aucun problème
avec c'est ce que je trouve qui est
drôle qui je trouve encore ce dont j'ai
toujours trouvé ça drôle c'est quand il
absolument aucune recherche qui fait sur
le produit puis quelqu'un ya des choses
qui sont m qui sont clés mais qui se
peuvent pau puis quand on voit
clairement qu'ils s'étaient faites en
échange d'une rémunération mais quel
personnage sans but complètement du
produit je trouve ça drôle je toujours
trouvé ça drôle puis je me sens vraiment
pas mal avec c est ce que j du bâclage
par rapport à ce vraiment pottas pour
vrai ça se peut qu'il ya plein de monde
qui l'on pense et puis qui se sont dits
acp et la tavarn actes et promet qui me
l'ont pas dit qui encore le je dirais
que je veux pourtant mes messages
mais j'ai vraiment vraiment beaucoup de
retours des gens qui trouvait ça drôle
on était quoi en gros le pôle des gens
comme moi qui n'ont servi mais je
réponds à la question à imposer à ma
prochaine questionner le fond c'est que
souvent des des cahiers jardé des
cahiers pour écrire dessus le meilleur
vraiment le tir à s'écailler leçon faite
en papier de chypre côté vraiment comme
over de top influenceurs puis ce que tu
disais sur le podcast avec harry c'est
moi c'est ce qui m'a marqué le plus
c'est ce que j'ai fait
créé à tarnac s'apprend après faut qu'on
réfléchisse collectivement ce qui se
passe parce que tu en aurais vendu des
cahiers il ya plein de monde mais
c'était clairement caricaturer le thé
ultime tome aurait vendu des cahiers en
tentant de la chose sur un produit qui
il existe elle est oui parce que des
gens qui m'ont écrit pour savoir qui
devait l'être pas 1000 soit pop voit ce
qu'on fait comment qu'on fait pour les
acheter tee le sait ça me ce que je
trouve être drôle au début m'a fait un
petit peu par pas je m'ai fait ouf
ok c'était une des premières choses que
je postais depuis que j'étais sorti puis
je continuer à agir et que mon compte
comme j'ai juste avant pis je n'avais
pas réalisé que le tout à coup il y
avait quand même une responsabilité qui
avait quand même un oui il ya des gens
qui ont peut-être pas ce filtre le pour
savoir si c'est vrai ou si c'est une
joke
c'est ça ma fait pas moins un point ben
c'est pas ça remet en question tu sais
pas ce qu'on en voit passer des affaires
qui ont qui ont pas de sens le tir des
infos qui ont fait le ch'ti d'affaires
qui fait que les abdos halle pour faire
seule c'est la pire aussi la pire à
force et le pire c'est pur produit le
faut ça marche pas demain on l'espère en
contractant des abdos que tu vas faire
des abdos genre c'est impossible
ça fonctionne comme cela fait pile heure
c'était en achètent
ouais c'est débile ça pas de sens puis
j'ai commencé à parler avec des foyers
des brunes qui me compte qu'ils me
contactent pour justement porté un
partenariat quoi que ce soit plus qu'en
célébrant ce que j'aime mais j'ai
commencé à leur offrir autre chose à
dire et au lieu qu'on fasse du contenu
poche le regarde comment j'ai un beau
manteau ge coppet et on essaie de faire
autre chose
je leur propose des idées que j'envoie
des decks et j'ai travaillé en strates
il s'est fait que je pose des idées tout
qui souvent ce que lebron me dit c'est
bon on est ouvert mais en même temps ça
marche pour keane bien de nokia is genre
d'une fille qui dit regarde mon beau
manteau ses offres nos jeunes exigent
iem seul et les gens consomment c'est ça
fonctionne bien et que je pense que tant
que ça va fonctionner il ya peu de
chances que sa chambre
puis en bout de ligne ça parce que si il
ya une partie du monde qui vont acheter
parce qu'il aime les produits tant que
ça mais parce qu'il met la personne qui
pousse les produits ti west la personne
qui pousse le produit fait pas un
minimum de background chèque de ses
conquêtes passées sous les jets ou situe
un bon produit de ce bail est monde qui
achète n'importe quoi l'enfant puis moi
je l ai vécu passé quand je disais que
j'allais fait deux fois le promouvoir un
produit
j'avais vécu me steenbrugge il ya une
compagnie qui m'ont envoyé des écouteurs
pikine qui me quittait pas comme os se
plaignent de la promotion plus mais j'ai
trouvé chez toi qui t'es pas cher je
trouvais qui tenait speed sopi j'en ai
parlé de ces écouteurs le puits les
demandes qu'ils ont acheté ça s'est
avéré qu'ils étaient en bonne compagnie
des deux drops shipping bonne compagnie
de job shipping démarre à peine
mais tous d'avoir vu une publicité
sponsorisée avec keven lapierre qui est
leur qui parle de ses écouteurs pour ont
fait rare ces écouteurs pourquoi est ce
que dans deux semaines tout le monde
parle d'un produit que j'ai jamais
entendu une maquilleuse de huit mois
s'était pas les mêmes parce que moi
c'était comme une petite compagnie steve
rogers de montréal mais j'en entends
parler des tirs et mais c'était vraiment
des c comme c'était comme des dictateurs
rapport dans le roman qui était à pied
pour elle je pense par une solide le jeu
commence vraiment moins cher que les
autres groupes il fonctionne ce papy
c'est moi il m'a envoyé ça a pris comme
trois jours était quand même y est c'est
ça il ya plein de monde qu'ils ont
essayé qui le monde super mal à l'aise
qui meurent écrivait pic était comme si
je suis tellement désolée d'être dérangé
avec ce métier
ça fait deux mois que j'ai acheté mes
écouteurs jpeg jpg pas de nouvelle jeep
moelleux comme gilles à rembourser le
monde de ma poche
mais le jeu sur ma vie j à coups de 5 en
2h44 j'ai filé comme la crise de vente
put y avait de monde le sait défi de
genre qui exhale le type qui doivent
faire genre et 14 casse de l'homme a
pris parce qu'on sera 3h de jobs le 8
octobre et ils n'auraient pas acheté
s'il l'avait pas vu sur mon compte fait
qu'il mena à partir de ce moment là même
pas pour ce que ça nous coûtait un
logement futé chiche en ces temps si
j'ai des soucis correct mais j'imagine
tout le monde qui m'ont peu écrit puis
qu'ils ont à jouer mais qui sont trop
mal pour m'écrire piger never again
ja oui je m'en partager des choses que
j'aime parce que je trouve ça cool mais
je veux être sûr en crise avant je veux
savoir d'où ça vient je vois avoir fait
mes recherches comme notamment autre
chose qui tombe entre les craques ti
s'il ya des lois pour des affaires là
mais c'est comme si le l'internet les
montres élevé technologie le monde
contre tamani j'avais genre une bonne
vieille pub en 208 agréable en chemise
beige chemise achètent ce qu'ils le
genre thème ap pop depuis le aucun belle
confirmation
ok rien aucun genre 3 qui ont agi
finalement genre d'or après genre un
mois et demi deux mois en refermant
trois mois plus tard je t'ai le kyste
est juste un scam georges et dans les
calmes qu'à remplacer quelqu'un qui
masque amis mais j'en deviens chemise
qui arrivera dans un papier tout emballé
tout croche je la sors elle est vraiment
moins belle que sur l'image appuyé là
dedans
bizarre à delà de la qualité de shit
sekkaki et j'ai reçu quelque chose mais
déjà ces annonces et timbales en
plastique boîtes en styromousse qui
arrive de l'autre bout genre en prenant
en continu de bateaux que c'est ça vous
pas tenté un oubli et lille les bonnes
vieilles brain grosses bennes qu'on
connaisse ce match et qui sait un jour
où genre de truc faire la maille à
montréal le 10 millions en espèces de 2
compagnies que tu vois ce reste agréable
que tu google le nom ça t'amène de bord
c'est comme est encore l'est ça revient
à ce genre de rêve qu'on nous vend
gentil des folies j'aimerais semaine à
acheter local tout qu'est-ce que je te
qu'est ce que je consomme quand cela
dont un artisan chez lui genre qui a
étudié puis que développer son propre
mais c'est des fois le quand les temps
sont durs le pilier sur amazon ça coûte
cinq fois moins cher mais il y a des
gens qui l'achètent sur amazon que je
peux pas notre leurs assauts parce que
bros tout est neuf pour tout le monde
j'en sais la coved pour tous moyens du
monde qui ont peu de jeu effectué ce
mardi achète les cales peace one day i
shot à 45
je comprends mal de houle tpiy j'étais
au pij dis pas que c'est pas la bonne
façon de papy se croyaient
définitivement mais société la mer genre
monoparentales que trois enfants qui dit
j'en rachète donjon le coton organique
faut qu aux gens qui quittent eux c'est
tout ce que tu parlais de came des scans
de ces compagnies low tech le tir et
nous autres on collabore sur le podcast
avec
memscap qui sont des produits pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture
on s'est dit c'est la vraie ils nous en
ont envoyé c'est une zone capote ses
produits mais ce qu'ils font ça partout
dans le monde sauf que là on faisait
jeter en contact avec la gagne aux
terriens terriens que la publication
date parce que notre notre comptabilité
au studio aussi la ferme et rien fait
c'est quoi ce virement la déco mindscape
le shcc telle compagnie qui nous paie
voici la facture tout le kit la ferc et
+ double vérifier parce que genre des
compagnies web comme ceux qui passent
par paypal souvent ces genres des
compagnies comme n'y a pas de taxes
inclus puis y'a pas de tuque est passé
de la pop c'est comme de quoi vraiment
sous la table sur paypal parce que pas
de trace comme a glissé cage les juste
vérifier maintenant mettre quelques
chopes certaines antennes mais c'est ce
qui attend un million qui font genre
avec ses codes et des espèces de shell
cover up pour blanchir du cash compagnie
des coûts non mais il ya de très fortes
chances que le problème ou sip c'est de
là que nous on a peut-être eu une
responsabilité c'est que moi je fais
quand même un minimum de recul
j'en fais pull à moins d'être vraiment
sûr mais cette fois ci j'avais quand
même fait un minimum de recherche puis
je veux dire avec moi le nom était
choquant mais commence à toutes les
autres ce site il ya un traitement des x
qui est différent parce que justement de
la plateforme pour promouvoir trimer toi
jéjé a pris notre stock enfermé
recherche qui fait la musique je savais
pas c'est la musique depuis longtemps
mais oui tu avais pas parlé fort hood et
une étaient gardées c'est sous ce nom là
bah oui comment sais tu sais pourquoi tu
as tu es ce que tu t'en fais encore que
ton corps enfin est-ce que ça va quand
partie ta vie et je pense que je vais
toujours faire de la musique pas cessé
c'est un athlète créatif qui est super
important pour moi j'en ai comme besoin
dans ma vie et à chaque période de ma
vie où je n'ai pas fait pendant
longtemps je filais beaucoup moins
inquiet je dors beaucoup moins bien et
fit cui j'ai toujours en fer est la
raison pour laquelle j'en ai pas parlé à
od c'est parce que c'est c'est comme
vraiment sacré pour moi la musique c'est
quelque chose qui vient d'une place
vraiment comme on en est et qui à ce
moment là c'était important pour moi de
départager les choses
et parce que je me serais vraiment pas
senti un être d'utiliser une plateforme
comme ça pour pour promouvoir de la
musique c'est je sais pas comment
l'expliquer mieux mais c'était juste peu
de choses qui s'alignait pour moi et il
ya aussi peut-être le parcours que j'ai
eus qui ont contribué à ce parce que
j'ai comme j'ai comme tombé dans la
musique à un niveau qui comme peu
naturel quand tu commences j'ai
collaboré avec des gens qui avaient des
jeux des super belle carrière qui a eu
un moment donné dans ma vie où est-ce
qu'il ait fallu que je disais qui j'aime
vraiment ce pour les bonnes raisons
si oui faut que je recommence même de
grandeur faut que je me clanche des
shows est-ce que trois personnes dans
salle où est ce que j'apprends alors je
vais vous frayer dans le diario as
cahiers du feedback il faut que je fasse
mes mais faut que j'aille me stripes
noise est piégé
je les fais tu là j'ai joué saad bensaou
de temps si tu vraiment que from the
ground up et des bas et on pense que ça
doit être quand jouissance et à quel
point ce pays
y'en a dit il y en ad devenue brune en
crise un beau rugby qui disent ah non
mais on un peu de
à qui vous avez deux guitares manouches
ndiaye va falloir que vous vous arrangez
tpiy 5 à 6 80 minutes % tchèque jan
hajek 6-3 de lyme siècle mais il fallait
que je le fasse ce qui est jeu
j'ai trouvé que si j'en avais comme
parler que j'avais voulu promouvoir à
travers rue des sarts probablement on
dirait que je me serais ressenti comme
je me sentais au début il y avait comme
un gros ce projet grosses bêtes light -
sur quelque chose qui peut qui peut
rendre le ou qui se veut peu quelque
chose de à grande échelle puis théologie
tonnes album décrit qui donne un bon
dans mon laptop is probablement que je
vais le sortir avant d'animer ça va être
ça va être quand s'abritant tt avec
trois retraits laupheim qui
ils répondent comme un groupe avec un
gros lancement mais peut-être que
portent ces deux cépages
non c'est clara pic car les quatre fils
qu'il a c'est le bon moment de faire ce
puits le jeu laissant pilot j faucheux
recall simple c'est le bon moment de
sortir ce piquant c'est vraiment fait
maintenant un an que je pense leona est
depuis naturel puis juste comme je le
fais pour les bonnes raisons drake
c'est là que ça donne de quoi qu' on
dirait que le monde a envie d'entendre
souvent plus c'est parce que ça cinq ans
et à notre sac ainsi comme juste ok
l'industrie hippique est ce que le monde
a envie d'entendre
qu'est-ce qui cible s'il faut oui le
mollah le monde essentiellement sont pas
content on goût d'entendre une artiste
qui kiwis luke qui met ses treize à
table je pense également
carmat puis je pense qu'au delà de ce
qu'il le monde a envie d'entendre
je pense j'ai encore plus grand jack est
ce que moi j'ai envie d'entendre ce soir
à faro si l'entente électrum entre moi
j'ai c'est que quand je vais le sortir
moi je vais content comme ceux que je
mixais si je pense à la maison des
artistes qui est je pense un bâton à
macau serra je peux citer que je parle
les deux danseuses et l'idf est un
projet musical que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup dit je ne serai jamais travers
ses films de thibaut ce tombeau sur une
tunique et m20 sur spotify plus choquant
c'est kitsch on se fait ma course et
rapide
on dirait que ça va être comme ce mot me
truc si les gens tombent dessus mais ils
vont trouver que c'est bon ou peu mais
ça sera pop parce qu'ils ont vu à eau
des métaux mais en même temps c'est que
ce soit quelque chose que tu es fier de
ça on va tenter d'en parler ah mais
c'est sûr que je vais en parler mais
mais pas par la part bon tu vois
utiliser un petit peu la notoriété
daudet pour mousser des trucs mais en
même temps ces bagues rex était fier de
ce que tu as fait ouais mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même une différence ente
telle est la personne que je suis à la
donne que cette personne là le fait audi
et que ça fait partie de moi tu es
mais d'en parler sur la plateforme de
audéoud été après monkey monde a dit
qu'on faisait les talents le parc de
toute beauté baissent pour moi c'est
vraiment deux choses séparées mais après
si j'évolue je fais des trucs petit oui
si j'ai fait et l'île de l'amour puis
retour et puis j'ai fait exclure examen
ça va faire partie de moi puis cette
personne ne va voir ce match avec 7 mai
ça serait comme un concert à qui
utilisent rennes 2 6 tonnes en générique
d'un film
je trouverais savoir comment je
comprends j'imagine que l'histoire peut
être vraiment longue a raconté puis là
on doit approcher les lourdes mais
comment justement je suis retrouvé à
faire des toons avec wyclef jean avec
des groupes d'artistes comme sur le tir
qui ça avoir passé par la traîne
justement de genre à faire des beach aux
pilotis 2010 a tranquillement conclure
mouche commence à ce prof pour vrai
c'est tellement un concours de
circonstances qui cherchait jamais
vraiment trop comment l'expliquer gt gt
baguette chanceuse et magie trendy dans
les studios j'avais un vrai amour pour
le songwriting fait que j'étais tout le
temps là et ces deux titres faire un
petit bac vocale sur la chanson de
quelqu'un ou août et participé à
l'écriture de quoi que ce soit pis j'y
passais ils mendient des journées des
semaines je me rappelle quand j'allais
momo cjp si j'étais dans l'équipe de
basket je ne sais mais pratique à laval
j'allais genre à saint-hubert phare du
studio pendant la nuit je ne venais
jardins cours à 8 heures à la vente où
j'étais vraiment comme je vivais le 10e
pour l'i ppte avec gang des amis qui
fait de la musique tombé tranquillement
pas vite au début non au début tu es
vraiment comme la fiction
c'est vraiment c'est tellement puis
j'apprenais puis gt gt comme une éponge
puis éventuellement ti c'est vraiment
une chose en amène une autre piste dû
faire un bon coup et maronites et écrire
un bon line sur la chanson quelqu'un
d'autre des rives réinviter sur une
autre session puis l'ami de quelqu'un
qui connaît quelqu'un d'autre puis
finalement bet e rencontre plein de gens
je pense qu'il ya aussi le fait que
j'aie jamais jamais rien demandé à
personne si je pense que ça m'a beaucoup
servi j'ai tout a été disponible pour
donner un coup de main mais jamais été
l'a fait quitter comme et du prêt
diffère un featuring avec moi exprès tu
t'es fait que ça c'est comme place et
naturellement je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
ce que je trouve qui est peut-être un
petit peu plus difficile c'est que quand
on connaît peu ou pas puis c'est
vraiment au comptoir cccb c'était bien
les jets comme question mais souvent par
le home ont même on m'associe aux autres
comme on met on utilise les quand on
utilise les réussites des hôtes dans et
dans ma description à moi qui donne
quand j'ai lu la description dans
différents midi par rapport au fait que
je fais et l'île de l'amour souvent
sales écrivait l'animatrice qui a déjà
travaillé avec jusqu'à cheikh sarr et
dix ans de tubes puis j'en ai accompli
des choses en tant que canadiens ont
peut-être plus petit mais sont à moi
j'ai travaillé fort pour qui je trouve
que une personne devrait pas avoir à
être définies par les gens qui à le
côtoyer ou qui a connu ou quoi que ce
soit parce que jean nipon grammy il peut
faire une tournée s'est lui dit bravo à
lui et moi j'ai mis plus petites
victoires sont à moitié de ce qu'est ce
qu'on doit
qu'est ce qu'on souhaitait on souhaite
et heures en mode avion ahmad avions way
qui on le souhaitait on me souhaiter
et je respire merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la
fin de ce père que vous avez apprécié
les conversations ça prouve que vous
êtes de réelles fans de conversation et
du sans-fil podcasts et on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe il ya sur
petra non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde culturel où
est ce que on parle d'homme ni que
l'émoi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on abordés pendant
le podcast donc allez sur notre page
culturelle et le lien vers ce havre dans
la description du podcast qui remercie
encore une fois de nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fin